欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这一节课我们来讲一下关于商品力怎么样去提升
商品力它里面主要就是两个指标
一个是全店的优品数
第二个就是储存优品占比
这个大家从字面上都能够很清晰的理解
全店优品数我们前面已经讲了它的具体的提升的方法
那么我们只要按照我们那些方法去提升就可以了
这里就是我们的一个数据的对比跟行业的数据对比
那么只要我们有差距说明我们还有一个提升的空间
那么我们还可以继续去提升
这边呢是一个近30天的趋势
我们可以来这里去看每一天的一个整体的一个数据
我们这样去看
也知道我们的数据大概的波动范围去提升就可以了
橱窗优品占比这种是很简单的
就是你把你的橱窗全部去选择优品,进入橱窗绑定就可以了
这是最容易达成的,这个是占比率,那么我们就很快就能够实现了
那么这个是定制赛道,这边的话是快速交易的,也是一样的逻辑,他们是没什么区别的
这个就是关于商品力提升的一些方法,我们就按照原始我们
讲的那些方法就可以了
这里的话我们来看一下RTS里面有一个可交易商品数也就是你发布的
RTS可以直接下单的产品
那么这个占比的话你可以根据你店铺的定位以及你的
真实产品去发布就可以了
这个的数量的话对你的整体的分子影响不是很大
如果是你做定制店铺的,那么这个的量可以适当的少一点,是没有关系的
如果你是做
快速交易这个赛道的,那么你这个量一定要
跟他们的
一样,或者是比他们的更多,这种才能够有更好的效果
我们所有的
数据
都不要低于行业的平均
只要低于行业的平均的话,那么我们整个店铺的效果都是比较差的
只有高于行业的平均
接近
行业优秀
这些店铺的效果才会更好
所以我们最低最低的标准就是
不能低于行业的平均
这些就是关于商品力提升的一些思路跟方法
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下一节课我们来讲营销力如何去提升